Lately, you've been engrossing yourself in studies
of human genetics and genealogies, and you're actually
pretty excited to start helping adopted individuals
find biological family members. An adopted individual contacts
you with their results from their 23andMe
report, showing that they actually have about 12.5%
identity by descent, IBD, with an unknown
person. That means they're genetically related to someone
at about 12.5%. So they want to know what this
means and how best to proceed. Now the adopted individual
doesn't understand this, and they've come to you because
they want to know what this 12.5% relatedness means. And
they also want to know how best to proceed if
they want to reach out and contact this person. So I
want you to tell me, what's the likely relationship that
this adopted individual might share with this unknown person, and
what advice are you going to give them to help them connect.